[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER HAAS: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to DA104, the Road to
Intelligent Transportation.
My name's Chris.
And along with my
peers down here,
Zef and Andrew, we're going
to be talking to you today
about how Google
and the Colorado
Department of
Transportation, CDOT,
are leveraging Google Cloud
Platform to bring intelligence,
efficiency, and interoperability
to CDOT's transportation
network.
A quick show of hands--
who commuted into San
Francisco this morning?
All right, half or so.
Who enjoyed it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTOPHER HAAS: And if this
was a interactive session,
I'd ask you, in the back, did
you go by bus or by shuttle
so you could actually
have some relaxing time?
And I would expect
most of us didn't, so--
while we're not solving
that problem today,
that is one of the goals that
we have in this partnership
is to try to alleviate traffic
congestion to help all of us
improve our commutes.
Before we dive in, a quick
reminder-- if we can accept
questions through
the Dory app, which
you can link to from
the Next application
and enter your questions.
And at end, we will have
time for both live Q&A
from the mics, as well
as answering questions
from the Dory.
So let's dive in.
So safety has always been the
number one goal for Departments
of Transportation.
While fatality rates have
decreased over the years,
in recent years,
we've seen an uptick
in the number of fatalities.
So what's causing this change?
Well, the number of
vehicles on the road
are increasing faster
than the number of people.
From 2016 to 2017,
we saw an increase
of 1.6% in the number
of registered vehicles,
compared to a 0.8% increase
in the overall population.
This is leading to more
congested and dangerous
roadways.
And DOT budgets
aren't increasing.
If anything, they're shrinking
while construction costs
are rising.
To answer this
transportation problem,
we shouldn't continue to do the
exact same thing we've always
done, which is
building more roads.
While that's definitely
needed, and it's
something we'll
definitely do, there's
not enough space to
continue to do that.
And also, it's
extremely costly, and it
takes years to see an
impact of congestion
for new construction.
One way we could improve upon
and optimize traffic management
is by viewing the roadway as
a highway for information,
versus a highway that
carries vehicles.
DOTs have spent decades
deploying traffic management
solutions that produce
massive volumes of data--
sidebar radars, toll
meters, weather stations,
traffic cameras.
Harnessing this data
from the roadway
will help us optimize traffic
both now and into the future.
The good news is that the
data we need does exist.
The not so great news is
that it generally resides
in very different
places and is generally
disconnected, leaving us with
a fragmented view, at best,
of what's happening
on the roadways.
And there's many different
transportation data
sources that exist, but, again,
they live in different places.
Critical data that we could
take advantage of now,
such as INRIX, GIS data,
Amber Alerts, traffic cameras,
are all over the place--
and even key data sources,
like Waze and Google Maps.
Without a clear
understanding of what's
happening on the
roadways, our communities
pay for mobility and
sometimes with their lives.
But what if we could bring all
this data together and even
let data be the driver
for traffic management?
We could enhance
situational awareness,
leveraging current
and historical data--
both situational data,
weather data, traffic data--
to respond to the traffic
incidents in near real-time,
the moment they happen.
We could coordinate response
across courtesy patrols,
towing, maintenance, law
enforcement, emergency
response, to respond to an
incident based on where it is,
from community feedback.
We could assess roadway
needs using data points
like traffic volume and
frequency, weather events,
community feedback,
to understand
where we need to do repairs in
a predictive way, on the roads.
With all this data
brought together in a view
that you know best, an
interface such as Google Maps,
you can harness the data to
answer some key questions,
things like, how has
traffic changed over time?
What alternate routes
can be utilized?
When is congestion
expected to peak?
And where are the most
trafficked roadways?
We can visualize this data with
Google Data Studio or partner
solutions from
Looker and Tableau.
You can overlay your
insights on a real-time view,
using Google Maps.
Once the data is
centrally organized
and available for both historic
and real-time analysis,
we can make
data-driven decisions,
helping to make roads
and drivers safer.
So why did CDOT choose
Google Cloud to build
its data-analytics system.
Google supports data
at petabyte scale
securely, with our
best-in-class data analytics
and machine-learning
capabilities
to inform real-time decisions
and to operate roadways.
For almost two
decades, Google has
been advancing the state of
the art for data analytics,
starting with our
initial research paper
on the Google File
System in 2002,
going to our map-produced
research in 2004,
and our NoSQL database
BigTable research in 2005.
We've been advancing
the state of the art
and creating a revolution that
the open-source community has
taken and, around that, have
built what many would say
is the best-in-class
data-analytic system in Hadoop
and in Apache HBase.
But Google didn't just stop
doing our research engineering
in these areas.
We've continued to advance
the technology, year on year,
to help power all
of our services
that we bring to you,
for example, Colossus,
which is our
next-generation file system,
or Dremel, which is our
scalable SQL engine,
to Flume and
Millwheel, which are
our next-generation
data-processing pipelines,
and to today, where we're using
TensorFlow for scalable machine
learning.
And while we're using
these for our own services,
we've also made them
available to you, to CDOT,
in Google Cloud Platform.
So you can take advantage
of these same services that
have been proven
inside Google for years
to now power your products,
and your applications,
and your services that you're
bringing to your customers.
And like I said, this
infrastructure powers Google's
8-billion-plus user services,
Google Search, Chrome,
Google Maps, YouTube,
Gmail, Google Drive.
But let's pause for a minute.
Let's actually think
about what these systems
are at their core.
And are they actually what they
appear to be on their face?
Is Gmail just a system for
sending and receiving email?
Is YouTube just a video
content delivery system?
Or is Android just a
mobile operating system?
What I'd argue is that
these are actually
massive globally-scaled
analytical engines
that leverage machine
learning to bring personalized
results to our users, when
and where they need them.
Google Cloud delivers
data analysis
through industry-leading
analytics and ML,
when and where you need them,
with security and privacy
in the forefront of our design.
We have four key
design principles
for our data-analytics stack.
And these are top of
mind for our customers.
First, our serverless data
analytics infrastructure,
our leadership in that space--
we are designing a
data-analytics stack,
or we have designed a
data-analytics stack
for the public cloud paradigm.
We're not lifting and shifting
traditional on-premise
architectures into the cloud.
This enables our
customers, all of you,
CDOT, to instead of focusing
on traditional infrastructure
like they normally would do,
to focus on analytics, which
is really what we
want is to focus
on the analysis of the
data that we're collecting.
We're building and offering
a comprehensive set
of core data-analytics
workloads,
from data warehousing,
to streaming data
analytics, to business
intelligence, to AI and ML.
Unlike vendors with one-off
solutions, this allows--
our approach to this is
a much more holistic view
of a data-analytics platform.
We also let our
customers operationalize
machine learning end-to-end.
ML training and prediction is
just one piece of the puzzle.
But offering up a
seamless ability
to collect, store,
transform, process,
and prepare data for ML gives
us an end-to-end solution.
We are deliberate in
making our ML stack simpler
for organizations
to adopt, so they
can derive information from
their ML initiatives faster.
And to finish off, we know this.
Google has proven the usefulness
of this infrastructure
through the services
that we offer.
We're at the forefront
of data analytics
and ML innovation for
the past two decades.
And the solutions
and frameworks are
available to our customers
today, who are now
adopting this and running their
mission-critical data analytics
apps on top of Google Cloud.
But it's not just
the cloud technology
that Google offers
that's important here.
It's also our history
and innovation
in the transportation space.
Organizations need
reliable, real-time data,
within user-friendly
views, to empower
employees to respond to
customers' demands and needs.
Google Maps offers
visualization, navigation,
and analytics to help lean
enterprises chart new territory
and to build transformative,
new opportunities.
Nobody understands
cities and what
happens within them, and
the people who live there.
Waze offers up a
data-exchange partnership,
where we provide a
publicly-available incident
and slow-down data to
our government partners.
Government's going to take that
data to both help them respond
to accidents more
effectively, and also
analyze congestion to find where
they can make improvements.
Driving today is not as safe
or as easy as we would like.
And Waymo-- their
mission is to make
it safe and easy for
people and things
to move around the world.
They're building a completely
self-driving technology
that will improve mobility
by giving people the freedom
to get around.
And it helps save thousands of
lives that are, today, being
lost to accidents.
So let's get into
DAISy and what it is.
So first the acronym--
Data Analytics
Intelligence System.
There is a flurry
of activity at CDOT,
which is intended to improve
the acquisition, processing,
management, curation, and
quality of the data set
CDOT has.
Tackling those
fundamental problems
will allow CDOT to enhance
the utilization of data,
create applications,
and solve use cases that
are becoming critical in
the rapidly transforming
transportation space.
Wes Maurer, who
unfortunately couldn't
be here, the head of policy
and innovation at CDOT,
along with the mobility
operations team,
is leading the charge for
adopting cloud computing
and real-time data
processing, with the goal
of enabling data
analytics and modeling
capabilities across CDOT.
The DAISy platform
has the potential
to solve many use-cases,
delivering better decision
to support and moving us closer
to data-driven decision-making.
There are many use cases that--
transportation use cases--
that CDOT focuses on.
And this is just a quick sample.
For example, transportation
planning, winter operations,
or situational awareness.
These use cases are
supported by a myriad
of disconnected
systems, such as SAP,
which has all budgeting
and financial information,
SalesForce, which holds
construction and project
details, to roadway sensors for
real-time mobile operations.
DAISy is a data
services and systems
layer which aligns the use
cases and the requirements
with transformed, enriched,
and coalesced data
from source systems,
and empowering end users
to achieve CDOT's key
performance measures.
DAISy will also be
the hub for enabling
new applications across
the DOT by delivering
historical and real-time
data and also leveraging
AI and ML for
predictive analytics.
So with all this in
mind, Google capabilities
with data ingestion,
exploration, and data science,
preparation of processing
and ML training, tuning,
and predictions,
this architecture
enables DAISy to become
a serverless analytics
engine for a complete
end-to-end lifecycle, delivering
CDOT's mission to bring
intelligence and insights
to the transportation space, to
their transportation network.
So now let's
introduce Zef, who's
going to come in and talk--
do a deeper dive into building
DAISy with data.
[APPLAUSE]
ZEF DELGADILLO: Thanks, Chris.
My name is Zef Delgadillo, the
technical lead on the DAISy
project, working with
Google Cloud and Cloudreach.
So when we kicked off this
project several months ago,
the first thing we had to do is
assess all the different data
sets that were
available at CDOT,
across their entire
technology ecosystem.
The first thing we
really discovered
is that there's kind of two
major categories of data
for a DOT or for transportation.
That's around your geospatial
data or streaming video data.
And Andrew's going to talk a
lot about the video streaming
data in a second.
But I'm going to go into
some of the geospatial data
and some of the
capabilities we're
unlocking by using that data.
Geospatial data is
really just any type
of data that has a
geographic component to it,
so a set of coordinates
associated with that data.
So we then broke that data down
into a few different major data
domains that are critical
to a DOT operation.
And that's really around
speed, weather, and incidents.
So speed-- how fast our
vehicle is traveling relative
to speed limit and moving
averages, and then vehicle
volume on the highway system.
Right now, that's
primarily detected
using some side-fire
radars that are fairly old.
Some of that data that
often comes out of it
is buggy or inadequate.
Weather data-- weather
data right now, for CDOT,
is collected using these
road weather information
system devices that also
live alongside the roadway.
So this becomes
kind of an IoT play
as we start getting into this.
The third data domain
is around incident data.
So basically, any kind of
traffic incident that gets
logged by the DOT operators
into their traffic-management
system.
So those are what we're
calling the legacy data sets.
One of the things
we wanted to do
is enrich that
with some new data
so that we can get
additional value out
of data sets that are
available publicly
or through different
organizations.
So for speed data, we
brought in data from Waze.
Waze is crowdsource
data that we can
track when jams are
starting to build up
on the highway systems.
And that gives us a better
picture of the roadway health
according to speed.
So right now, CDOT
is detecting speed
using an algorithm
that really only
takes into account the data
coming from side-fire radars.
So by bringing in Waze data,
we can get additional value out
of that.
Weather data-- this is a
really cool data set produced
by the National Center
for Atmospheric Research,
called Pikalert.
Pikalert has these vehicles
traveling up and down
major trucking routes in
Colorado, particularly I-70,
and it detects road conditions.
So if there's an icy road
or there's snow on the road,
you'll get back data
around snow depth
or whether that road
needs to be treated.
Incidents-- so Waze is another
great data set for incidents.
Crowdsource accidents that
people are putting in can be,
now, added in addition
to the DOT events
that are getting logged.
So we wanted to make this
data a little bit more
accessible to DOT users.
Chris mentioned that this
data existed in a lot of silos
all over the DOT.
It was in Salesforce, SAP.
We had to do this massive
Oracle Data Warehouse migration.
So we basically brought in
terabytes of historical data
into Google Cloud BigQuery.
And we set up this sort
of abstraction layer
on top, to make it a little
bit more accessible to someone,
maybe, who has a lot of domain
expertise in the transportation
space, but doesn't
want to be bogged down
with trying to remember what
table to join on to derive
value out of those data sets.
So we created simple,
business-friendly entities
at the top view layer, in the
form of views in BigQuery,
and created a data
set called DAISyMart.
With that, we're using a
business-intelligence tool,
Looker, that utilizes these same
entities to kind of democratize
this data a little bit more.
So here's kind of a simplified
view of our architecture.
Really, it's all kind of
centered around Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub enables us to,
basically, use streaming data
across all these
different data sets.
So even in cases where we're
batching in data-- so Waze,
we might be reaching out every
five minutes to get the latest
Waze data--
we could still
translate it to Pub/Sub
and have a series
of Pub/Sub topics
that are kind of like-- you
can think of them as spigots
you would attach a hose
to, to pull in that data.
So it enables any, really,
application or user
to pull in data from Waze
or data from the IoT devices
and build out their
applications with it.
We're pushing all that data
into BigQuery and BigTable.
And on the right,
you can kind of
see how we're looking at DAISy.
And it's sort of like a
three-pronged platform.
You have event-driven
data in Pub/Sub,
like I mentioned before, near
real-time data in Google Cloud
BigTable, and the
analytics layer that
uses BigQuery and Looker.
Geospatial data-- so I mentioned
before that geospatial data
is-- its kind of special.
It's kind of important to CDOT.
And we wanted to use some
kind of best-in-class tools
to sort and analyze that data.
So GeoMesa is our first one.
GeoMesa is an open-source
tool for, basically,
massive geospatial
querying and ingestion.
It stores in Google
Cloud BigTable,
and it does all its
processing in Apache Spark.
So you can run it on
a Dataproc cluster.
It transforms indexes and then
stores that geographic data
for rapid access.
So you can query,
basically, on either time
or some kind of geography.
You could pick like a
window of space on a map
and then get all of the data
available through there.
GeoServer is the other
tool we're using.
And that's our mechanism to
share that geospatial data.
So it uses GeoMesa as
it's back-end data store.
We're running it on
Google Kubernetes Engine,
and it publishes
data to, really,
any kind of geographic data
standard, including GeoJSON.
GeoJSON has kind of emerged as
a de facto standard for sharing
geographic data over the web.
So a couple use cases that,
after a few months, really,
we were able to unlock using the
computational power of Google
Cloud BigQuery.
So CDOT has its concept
of a road segment.
And a road segment is
really just a stretch
of road between two points
going in a single direction.
And that road segment has a
set of geographic coordinates
associated with it.
So using Google
Cloud BigQuery, we
can basically attach these
Waze accidents, or incidents,
off to the road segments.
So when you're querying, or
somebody who-- a transportation
planner is querying on the
health of that road segment,
not only do you get the
events that the DOT logged,
you also get the Waze accidents.
So this is a really
powerful, new tool
that we can unlock using the
computational power of Google
Cloud BigQuery, that using
their on-prem data warehouse
just wouldn't have
been possible.
Enabling situational
awareness and replay--
so this concept of
situational awareness
is understanding what's
going on in the DOT.
So if you ever go to a
DOT operation center,
they've got all these maps
and all these different camera
views all over the place.
And they're toggling between
Waze and Google Maps--
their own mapping systems--
to understand what's going on.
So with the architecture
that we built,
we're enabling this
mechanism to build out
some kind of situational
awareness layer.
And on top of that, we can
now, using the platform,
replay an existing event.
So a few weeks ago, there was
this big storm in Colorado.
They called it a bomb cyclone.
And we were able to capture that
data using our DAISy platform.
And it gives us the opportunity
to replay that event
and watch how all these
different layers interplayed,
so that a transportation planner
can go back, review an event,
and understand how
they can better
prepare for it in the future.
Kepler.gl is an
open-source mapping tool
produced by Uber, which I think
is pretty cool that there's
this sort of
disruptive technology
that we can now reapply to
the DOT, which has been around
forever.
So I'm using Kepler as
just a mechanism to demo
out this GeoServer, GeoMesa
data-processing system
that we've set up here.
So this is kind of a cool video.
We're basically replaying
all of the Waze accidents
that occurred during
the bomb cyclone.
You can see that
they kind of just
dip to nothing here because so
few people were on the roads.
But this sort of gives
an interactive way
of a user to take a look
at the roadway health
and create geospatial
visualizations, which
is a capability that would
not have been possible
in the previous ecosystem.
A similar thing with speed--
so we can kind of
detect highway speeds.
It's going to go
really red in a second.
And the cool thing
is that we're really
animating millions of
entities right here that we're
pulling in.
From GeoServer, we're just
getting a GeoJSON endpoint,
pushing it into
kepler.gl, that Uber tool,
and then we can immediately
animate and then
replay across a historical set.
So this really is
just a demonstration
of the future capabilities
that we're trying to unlock.
By building out this
underlying platform
and that infrastructure, we have
a lot of really powerful tools
at our disposal.
With that, I'm going to
pass it off to Andrew.
I'm going to be at the
Google Public Sector booth,
and I'm happy to go through
a demonstration of Kepler
in a little more detail
if you'd like to see it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW SCHWARTZ: Thanks, Zef.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Andrew
Schwartz, and I'm
a product manager for Video
AI, here at Google Cloud.
At Google Cloud AI, we have the
mission to empower enterprises
to transform their
business with AI.
For CDOT, video is a great
example of this transformation.
CDOT currently has hundreds
of roadside cameras collecting
valuable information every day.
However, this information
has not been fully utilized,
as it has been too difficult to
reliably and scalably analyze
these videos and collect
the data from them.
However, that is why
CDOT decided to leverage
the power of Google Cloud AI,
to help them bring intelligence
to his legacy camera systems,
without the need for replacing
them for higher-resolution
and higher processing power
cameras.
At Google Cloud AI, we offer
two types of AI building blocks
to help customers build--
or add human-like capabilities
to their products.
The first I'd like to talk
about is the pre-trained APIs.
The pre-trained APIs allow
customers to leverage Google
predefined data sets to
meet common use cases
and fully trained models based
on the latest breakthroughs
in AI technology and research.
The second is AutoML.
Even for expert data scientists,
it's quite difficult for them
to train and program
custom computer-vision,
machine-learning models, which
is why we created AutoML.
AutoML enables even
non-programmers to leverage
a simple user interface
to create custom models.
All they have to do
is upload labeled
data sets, and then with a
simple click of a button,
train a custom
computer-vision model fit
to their specific domain,
or specific use case,
and deploy it to production.
Today, building upon
this, we're really
excited to announce
that we've added
additional functionality to our
Video Intelligence streaming--
Video Intelligence APIs in the
form of streaming capabilities.
Now enterprises
have the flexibility
to not only process
large video archives that
are stored in Google
Cloud Storage,
but also to analyze
videos in real time
and get actionable
insights right on the spot.
With live streaming support,
we have initial support
for live streaming protocols,
such as HLS, RTMP, and RTSP,
initially.
So with the power of
the pre-trained models
and the streaming API, CDOT
is able to bring intelligence
to their existing camera feeds.
For instance, CDOT leverages our
pre-trained object-tracking API
to extract valuable
information and detect
different types of vehicles
and track their movements
throughout the day.
This information helps them
understand traffic patterns,
as well as identify trends
and make decisions off of it.
Or they can leverage our
label detection in AutoML
to monitor road conditions, to
identify whether it's snowing
or whether there's snow on the
road, which can further enrich
weather data as part of DAISy.
The streaming API allows
customers to leverage
or harness the power of a
cloud to do video processing
at scale.
But it gives them the
flexibility to take the results
and either process it
further on Google Cloud,
or to view the
results on-premise,
in their application.
To help you get started
and easily connected
to Google Cloud
streaming API, we
provide AI streamer, which
is our ingestion library,
and a set of sample code to
easily process-- or chunk
the videos and send it
to the cloud for you.
Here, we provide a simple
architecture-- or a sample
architecture-- for how you
might connect and utilize
the streaming API.
AI Streamer takes in the
video feeds and sends it
to the cloud for
analytics and storage.
With this, you can then run the
pre-trained Video Intelligence
APIs to extract
valuable information
from your video feeds and then
pipe the results in the cloud
Pub/Sub, where that
information can then
be passed to your
application in the cloud,
such as it is for DAISy, or back
to your application on site,
for a visualization.
So what does this all mean?
It means that when you construct
a valuable video information
and combine it with DAISy
data, other DAISy data sources,
you can solve real
transportation problems.
You can reduce costs.
You can optimize roads.
We can help you get
home quicker from work.
We can make the
roads safer for you
and to have you spend more
time doing what you love
and less time spent on the road.
OK.
Next, we'll show a quick demo of
one of our object-tracking APIs
running--
or pre-trained models-- running
on one of DAISy camera feeds.
This is pre-recorded,
but if you would
like to see a
live-streaming demo,
you can come by the Public
Sector booth later today,
or later this week, and see,
actually, a live feed being
ingested, as well as the
bounding boxes overlaid
for the different videos.
So with this, you can track the
movements of different vehicles
crossing through an
intersection and keep these data
or store them as part of DAISy.
Next, Chris will
actually tell you
some information regarding
this, around how much
data is actually being
extracted from these videos,
even with the small number
of cameras, currently.
CHRISTOPHER HAAS:
Thanks, Andrew.
So to pivot on what Andrew
talked about with the Video
Intelligence streaming
API, a few weeks ago,
we deployed video-streaming
infrastructure
from CDOT's
on-premise data center
to Google Cloud,
the DAISy platform.
And we've been collecting
data ever since,
on only four cameras.
So I want to quickly just
give a view of how we're
using this metadata-- in
addition to the bounding box,
the video stream that you saw,
how we're using this metadata
to gain further insights that
CDOT originally did not have.
So CDOT has roughly 488-some
odd cameras connected
to their network, in addition
to thousands of others that
are connected over cellular.
These cameras are
all legacy devices.
They're not intelligent.
They're not giving data out.
They're just live streaming so
that an operator can view it.
On the right-hand side,
one of the cameras
happens to be in South
of Denver, on I-25.
And that's a still
image of that camera.
We've been extracting data
around vehicle counts,
both total by hour, by day,
and averages by weekday.
And you can see each of
those heat maps, accordingly.
And now, we can take these
non-intelligent devices,
extract data from
them, and have insights
into what is visible
in that live stream.
And this would correlate--
if you look in the heat maps
there, it correlates to
increases in traffic volume
throughout the day, aligning
with what we would normally
know as our commute times.
So to give you an idea of the
volume we're operating out
here-- so four cameras.
They've been
operating for 13 days.
And over that time,
we've ingested
over 60 million data
points for labels
and over 21 million objects.
Now, granted, not
all of this data
is necessarily useful
for every use case.
But just think, you went
from almost zero data
points, besides what a human
would see out of a camera,
to, now, ingesting
all of this data
into a scalable data
warehouse in BigQuery.
So now we can analyze it
both real-time, as well as
historical.
So to give you a view
of where we're going--
where we've been and
where we're going--
here's a tentative roadmap
for what this partnership is
going to go forward with.
So starting in March,
you see at the bottom,
we did our executive review
that closed out phase I.
For phase I, we delivered
a technical systems plan
for the DAISy system.
We built out core
infrastructure for DAISy,
as well as multiple
data-integration pipelines.
We also did-- we're
doing a full sync of all
their historical data from
their Oracle Data Warehouse,
and we have a migration
plan for that as well.
We also delivered a
technical system plan
for a modernized Colorado
traffic-management system.
Now going forward, we're
looking to continue building out
more of the core
system, build out
multiple data-integration
pipelines
beyond what we have today.
And if you remember
the slide back,
we had all those myriad
disconnected systems.
There's lots of those that we
need to build pipelines and get
into DAISy.
So we'll continue to do that.
We'll do a full migration of
the Oracle Data Warehouse.
We're building multiple
real-time visualization
interfaces, such as the example
that Zef showed with Kepler.
We're also going
to explore doing
the development for
a modernized Colorado
traffic-management system,
and modernizing and hosting
their COTrip.org
public-facing website,
in GCP, being powered
by real-time modern APIs
from DAISy.
We're also going
to explore building
a data-discovery platform, in
a real-time data hub that CDOT
will use to, both, do
data analytics broadly
across the DOT, as well as
new application development.
So in closing, CDOT
and Google have
partnered to build DAISy,
which will aid CDOT
in delivering on their
key performance measures.
For example, improved
safety and mobility,
increased social equity,
highly-responsive traffic
operations, and collaborative
data and information sharing
and communications.
So right before I end,
just I'll reiterate,
if you want to see live
demos of the technology
we've shown, go to the industry
solutions area, and the Public
Sector booth, specifically.
We have multiple live
demos that you can look at.
And also, you can ask questions
to members of the DAISy team.
So thank you for
attending the session.
I hope it was useful.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]